les quatre ascensions dont c'est
notamment là nous avait quitté l'udf en
place l'opposition comme conseil
constitutionnel pour amender le corriger
la loi comme externes bouteilles et les
députés au grand complet afin de cibler
plus tard c'est fait le texte étant sans
doute après un an de bataille
parlementaire et de 1775 mais dans
l'opposition nous et devant le conseil
constitutionnel et notamment lorsque la
droite appelle le fichage des personnes
il est fondé sur la première
la loi a pour objet d'obliger les
homosexuels a déclaré leurs pratiques et
négligé de nouveaux droits c'est une
atteinte à la vie privée
la droite juge également que les
gratifications fiscal du pacs sont
contraires au principe d'égalité
mais pour les spécialistes ne sont pas
sûres c'est une oif personnel c'est une
mois à partir de sa saisine le conseil
constitutionnel dispose d'un mois pour
se prononcer la bataille du pacs n'est
pas encore permis